gestern haben wir hier über das
gespenstische droh video eines
abgeschobenen afghanen berichtet
inzwischen zieht es weitere auch
politische kreise und wir schauen noch
mal ganz kurz um was es da genau geht
er ist schwer kriminell wird 2017 nach
afghanistan abgeschoben und bedroht nun
unsere polizisten und mitglieder der
spezialeinheit sek mit dem tod
bandenchef sangha ahmadi ich werde
erstmal sein der bullen tötet ohne 2 sek
beamte getötet - 2000 sagt geht dann
werde ich dafür sorgen dass ich 100 auf
ghana die auch die paläste sitzen wie
werde ich auf erziehen unsere mutter
[ __ ] rückblick sangha ahmadi stammt
aus kabul ist deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden seit jahren als
unterwelt könig wegen erpressung
vergewaltigung sexueller nötigung und
unter anderem gefährlicher
körperverletzung bekannt vor vier jahren
wird er nach afghanistan abgeschoben mit
dem widerlichen droh-video will er nun
offenbar weitere polizeikontrollen in
seinem privaten und geschäftlichen
umfeld auf brutalste art und weise
verhindern afghanen die auf der
abschiebe liste stehen sollen in seinem
auftrag in deutschland vergewaltigen und
töten jetzt der rückzieher sangha ahmadi
veröffentlicht auf seinen sozialen
kanälen ein zweites video spricht davon
dass man ihn nur falsch verstanden hätte
experten sprechen von reine
schutzbehauptungen
ja und genau dieses video schauen wir
uns jetzt einmal an eine entschuldigung
die völlig absurd klingt
ja ich kann auf jeden fall meiner seite
besser gesagt unsererseits und dem
deutschen behörden den deutschen
polizisten auch dem deutschen volk
hundertprozentig versichern dass wir
nicht vorhaben jemand für töten oder
ansatzweise daran so denkt ich würde das
video kurz zu machen um mich bei manchen
menschen und die das video vielleicht
offene art und weise falsch verstanden
haben entschuldigung das video gilt oder
geht nicht an dass deutsches volk an die
deutsche behörden auch mich an die
deutsche polizisten ich habe
garantierten gegen himmel oder gegen
eine deutsche polizisten umzubringen um
gottes willen
tja wirkt sich diese entschuldigung
vielleicht sogar
strafmildernd aus das klären wir jetzt
mit dem strafrechtsexperten matthias
waldraff guten tag herr wallraff
er war darauf welche strafrechts
bestände können gegen den mann überhaupt
erhoben werden
ja diese hasserfüllten erklärungen
erfüllen fraglos den tatbestand
nicht nur der bedrohung und beleidigung
sondern auch die störung des
öffentlichen friedens durch die
androhung
von mord totschlag gefährliche
körperverletzung also schön und
verbrechen und die entschuldigung die er
jetzt ausgesprochen hat mach dir alles
wieder wett ist damit alles wieder gut
beide videos sieht und nebeneinander
stellt und nicht nur den inhalt der ja
voller voller hass ist und im ersten
sondern auch die mimik die körpersprache
sie die vielzahl an brutalsten
wiederholungen wenn es auch um verwandte
von polizeibeamten sek geht macht
deutlich dass dieses erste video das
maßgebende ist und das zweite ist der
gescheiterte versuch das zurückzuholen
das steht für mich außer frage und
dieses erste video wird meist gegen zeit
für die ermittlungen und ihr drohen dann
auch massive strafen die große koalition
hat noch im april 2021 eine massive
verschärfung gegen delikte hetze hast
netz das ist hier also ein beispiel
durch gebracht die strafen sind durchweg
verdoppelt worden auch für bedrohungen
dass die bis zu drei jahren straft rom
und jemand der so viel mitbringen wie er
an vorbelastungen und kriminellen
vorstrafen der wird auch nicht nur
bewegung zu sehen sein also das heißt
angriff ein haftbefehl reichen
die frage eines internets bester
internationaler haftbefehl von weiteren
faktoren ab
aber wenn da bestimmte weitere
voraussetzung erfüllt wären könnte man
daran denken andere fragen sind berührt
auch etwaige auslieferung wenn was ja im
augen steht der mann sich im moment in
der türkei aufhalten sollte und dort
überhaupt greifbar wäre dann würde
möglicherweise auch die türkei nicht
ausliefern weil immer noch kein
verbrechen ist arg bestände geführt wäre
von mindestens einem jahr
freiheitsstrafe
es bleibt immer noch im bereich das
verdienst aber das sind dann so
spezialfragen da sollte man jetzt nicht
spekulieren
fakt ist dass dieses video genau das ist
was die koalition
im frühjahr meinte unter anderem wir
gehen hier auch in die nähe des
terrorismus verdacht die irgendwann ende
und dann die jetzt gott sei dank
massivere strato und
das fehlt hier eine
frage jetzt ja auch die bundesregierung
überhaupt eine interesse an einer
auslieferung hätte und den mann dann
wieder hier im land hätte um ihn dann
später wieder abschieben zu wollen
wenn ich richtig das sehe ich auch so
nur eins ist mir sehr wichtig dass die
verschärfung dieser paragraphen im
strafgesetzbuch
gerade gegen hetze und hass
die wertigkeit derjenigen gestellt und
das sind hier vorher nicht polizeibeamte
in überwiegend essen hier konkret
angesprochen werden in den
nichtöffentlichen teil des videos dass
sie gezeigt haben
brauchen auch diesen schutz und diese
unterstützung und da sollten wir jetzt
noch alleine zahlen
[Musik]